now
some 340
years ago a warship called the
gloucester ran aground on a sand bank
and its whereabouts were unknown but now
after a four year search the wreck has
been discovered off the coast of norfolk
i'm pleased to say i'm joined now by the
brothers who discovered the wreck
lincoln and junior
farnwell lincoln julian good morning to
you well quite a discovery
good morning thanks for having us on the
show it's an amazing two days it's so
great to share the story of everybody
yes good morning
so
to come out now to the to the public
it's kind of feel like a full circle and
they're really enjoying the moment
go on and tell us about how you've
managed to go about finding this thing
four years in the searching am i right
yes so i'm glad to say we had a
fantastic day when we found you and our
father was with us
and a good friend james little and
lincoln had the first dive so perhaps
he'd like to tell you about what he
actually saw when he landed on the cb
yeah so it all started from a
you know traditional book
and i was flicking through the pages one
night of this big archive of shipwrecks
around uk
went back and back in time and saw a
wreck on 1682 uh sank in 1682 for the
gloucester um and just saw the cannon
and the future king of england was on
board picked the phone up that night
called my brother to see if he'd be up
for um go looking for her i knew he
would
and that was our mission and um four
years in um we found her i was lucky one
to dive at first which is just
obviously what i shall never forget
it's really impressive i mean just tell
us um
what kind of depth of water were you
guys diving in to find the gloucester
yeah well she's in shallow water so we
have to be a bit careful on the death
but um
the important thing about the site is
very intact and she sang within 45
minutes he listens they had the royal
future king of england on there and his
royal court so it was a high status ship
and she sank in the early hours of the
morning within 45 minutes and the site
is only like 50 meters by 30 meters and
it's laden with surface artifacts uh
we're really just started working on it
we're working with all the right people
we've got a fantastic team there's a lot
more work to be done and we have an
exhibition coming up next year in the
norwich castle the norfolk museum
service uh um
the museum i've got the exhibition going
on for three months and so we have you
know tell everybody about the story and
the people on board yeah i mean as we're
talking we're seeing some of the
artifacts that have been pulled from the
rock so far i mean and
it ran the ground on a sandbank i know
this was 1682 and they didn't have gps
back then but how did it manage to to
come come around on a sandbank do we
have any idea about who was in charge
although there was a future king on
board
so um basically they picked up picked up
a local pilot from great yarmouth and
that's where we are today and um he was
going to navigate through some
treacherous sandbanks off the north
coast
and then uh
the future king had a very robust
discussion with the pilot and actually
chose to choose his ignore his local
device and um he went to bed and then by
the early hours of the morning whilst
everybody's sleeping unfortunately hit a
sandbank and then they smashed the
rudder and sprung a leak on the stern
and couldn't save the vessel so he had
to ban from the ship sadly there was 130
to maybe 200 souls lost and we must
always remember that
yeah absolutely right i mean that's
quite a large number of people who
unfortunately died in this incident it
was a just make sure i'm clear on that
it's a disagreement between the king and
the local pilot as to which how they
should navigate through the sandbanks
that's absolutely right and uh this was
witnessed by a lot of his royal court we
had john churchill on there the first
duke of marlborough and our historians
from the university of east anglia
believed this was the start of losing
faith in james ii and questioning his
decision-making and that obviously had a
knock-on effect this is a classic
what-if story you know if the duke had
died or even john churchill we wouldn't
have winston churchill so it's
fascinating assets to this particular
wreck site great history story
yeah absolutely right an amazing story a
great discovery uh lincoln uh julian
thank you so much for that um just
quickly it you're not gonna try and
bring this thing up and put it on
display are you that's good it's gonna
stay beneath the waves
we've got so much more work to do as
many seasons and we'll be led by the
archaeological work and we've got a
brilliant team working with us so
whatever's at risk we'll decide but um
there's substantial wreckage but there's
no plans for that at the moment
sure thing all right lincoln julian
thank you so much for that an amazing
discovery appreciate your time and a
lovely looking day there in great
yarmouth enjoyed this